let's try it okay a man in a boat
okay
man in a boat is four kilometers
from the nearest point o on a straight
beach so
the beach is straight
okay as all beaches are and um
o is the nearest point to him on the
bench so nearest means
perpendicular
so there's o okay uh that distance is
four kilometers
okay he's been rowing for a while his
destination is four kilometers
wait hold on yeah that's right same
distance four kilometers along the beach
from oh so we should put it over this
way
right so i'm gonna put it four
kilometers four kilometers
let's call that his destination
yeah okay and it's four kilometers away
from that nearest point
okay yeah question just stretching cool
okay if he can row at four kilometers an
hour
uh rowing speed
and he can walk at five kilometers an
hour
the question is um how should he proceed
in order to reach his destination
in the least possible time
how should he proceed now classic
maximum question
in that um even the question itself
doesn't make clear
like what equation am i going to solve
differentiate all that kind of thing you
got to build all of that yourself we did
we looked at that in previous lessons
okay so
what kind of options does he have i
think there are kind of three main
options
that he can do in terms of how he can
get from where he is
to his destination what are the ways you
could do it
okay he could go straight from here
diagonal path
directly okay
that's one way how else could he do it
okay good let's let's take the simpler
case first
okay yeah
he's he's jesus so he could just walk
and this is fine
um simpler case first i could roll all
the way
right or i could row the shortest
distance possible
and then walk the remainder yeah so i
probably should write these down
options one is
row directly
okay number two was row to
the closest position
uh namely o and then walk his third
option was actually the one you
mentioned
uh earlier which is he doesn't have to
row directly to the beach
he could rotate some point in between
and then walk whatever is left over
okay so he could do something like this
there and then across does that make
sense
so he could row to
some intermediate point
and then walk okay
now who's done this question before
before question 26.
is it the same numbers uh no different
numbers okay now
that'll that'll be that'll be important
and you see what i mean by there's not
that many kinds of questions and you
probably should have done the one where
there's a wire
and it cuts in two and then you make two
shapes out of it or that kind of thing
so it's all different variations on
sometimes it's a triangle
sometimes a circle or sometimes a square
rectangle whatever okay
so now as you'll see in a second um
these these numbers here four four four
five
okay they turn out to be crucial okay
just tweaking them a little bit
changes the nature of the question quite
significantly all right now
what do you guys reckon what would you
vote who reckons rowing directly is the
fastest way
hands up ends up
i mean the i guess the reason why no
one's biting is because rowing is is
slower right it's significantly slower
it's 20 slower okay so i got zero
votes for rowing directly who reckons
rowing to o
and then walking is the fastest yeah a
couple of takers
yeah okay two people for that right so
that means i take it the rest of you
think it's an intermediate point
yeah roughly yeah so that's like that
yeah well like i have no idea should i
okay
all right now yeah sorry
all right now that that's fine that's
interesting i think that's that's the
normal instinct okay because this is
going the slowest
method this is going the longest
distance
right because it totally travels eight
so we think okay in between
it's probably about right now even if
this is correct we need to know
what is that intermediate point where on
the beach is it gonna go
okay so we need to call it something so
i'm going to call it p
p for point okay so if you've got your
diagram there
okay have all this inscribed on it
now uh remember we wanted to set up the
question we're still in the first
c the construction step right i've got
no equations yet
yeah what equations could i build off of
this
pythagoras is going to be involved right
because i'm going to need to know
what um this distance is all right uh in
order to work out this this is though
i've got to work out this distance right
and that's sort of i don't really know
that's that's the point go to some
some intermediate point okay so here's
where we're going to introduce a
variable okay
let's call we call this x we call this x
what do you think
this one let's call this one x
okay so let x
actually i should have said let p let p
be some point between
o and the destination
and we're going to call this distance op
be well this is in kilometers right
okay great so i'm almost there i can
actually now start to build some
equations
right this whole thing is about
minimizing the amount of time this takes
yeah so i'm going to take that
the whole you know length of the journey
let's call it something like say t
okay um opv x kilometers and
t be
the total time
i suppose this is all in hours so let's
stick with the same unit of time
for the whole journey
okay
kind of equation can i build here now
because we're going with this this idea
here
okay this is going to require two pieces
to my equation my t
equation okay t is going to be equal to
the first part of the journey namely the
rowing part
and the second part of the journey the
name of the walking pattern i've got to
add those times together
okay so how do i get the rowing time
well in terms of journeys right
a time is going to be speed on distance
right
sorry just it's on speed let's get that
right
no i don't mean displacement distance um
sorry yeah that's helpful isn't it later
on when we do
year 12 motion you'll figure out the
difference between distance and
displacement
anyway so therefore i need to know well
speed's okay
i've got that as a constant i need to
know the distance yeah
so i've already got x i've got four here
so what does that make this
distance here
you happy with that as the distance okay
and obviously it's gonna
take you that long so there's time one
okay then i've got to add the other time
right
so how long how far does he walk it
walks this distance here
right so i'm going to subtract yeah
and that's the speed please
okay
now does this equation work for um our
other options
well rowing directly if he wrote
directly what would distance x be
it would be four right so that means
that
you're going to get this part and this
will be zero because there's no walking
so in fact you might even want to
say label on your equation right this is
your row component this is your walk
component
so if x equals four there's no walking
component okay
by the same logic uh if x is equal to
zero right which means he goes directly
to the shore
then you're going to row four kilometers
route 16 on four or four yeah
yeah yeah okay and then
you're going to wait one second yeah of
course that's the time
and then you're going to walk the
remainder right so that works it does
actually work
which is nice this equation which we've
built for this actually fits both of
those situations which will be important
all right so i've set up my equation now
what
get rid okay i need to check if i've got
any variables that i need to eliminate
uh thankfully the way we built it right
for instance i didn't call this x and
this y
i just have one letter x okay so i'm
actually done with that
so that's fine anything else i need to
do
ah i'm going to get into calculus in a
second but i want to note the
restrictions first
okay so what restrictions are there on x
we actually mentioned the restrictions
when we were talking about these two
situations here
okay if he rose directly x is equal to
four
okay and it wouldn't make much sense to
have x be bigger than that because that
means he's rolling past his destination
backpedaling okay in the same way if he
rose to the point that's closest to o
then x equals zero right and it doesn't
make much sense to make it negative
because you're going to be rolling away
and then you're gonna have extra walk
okay so therefore we're gonna get this
kind of domain
okay